la resolución ha sido presentada por la
República de vanuatu que se encuentra en
el Pacífico es un estado insular formado
por 83 Islas que hasta hace poco era un
auténtico paraíso pero poco a poco se ha
ido destrozando con el cambio climático
para que os hagáis una idea cada año
sube 11 centímetros el nivel del mar y
un grado la temperatura están en primera
línea de esta crisis climática por eso
han presentado esta resolución después
de cuatro años de trabajo y de
negociaciones que ha contado con el
apoyo de 121 países y que básicamente le
está pidiendo a la Corte Internacional
que conteste a dos preguntas primero
Cuáles son las responsabilidades que
tiene cada país en cuanto a la crisis
climática que estamos atravesando y que
está afectando solo sobre todo a los
países subdesarrollados que al final son
los que menos contaminación emiten y por
otro lado Cuál es la responsabilidad
jurídica Cuál es ese castigo jurídico
para los países que no cumplan con estas
responsabilidades y sigan aumentando ese
efecto invernadero con los gases que
emiten sus ciudades Estas son las dos
preguntas que pide la resolución que la
Corte Internacional conteste hoy el
secretario general de Naciones Unidas
Antonio Gutiérrez ha dicho que la crisis
climática es una sentencia de muerte
para los países menos desarrollados a
esto se le ha llamado justicia climática
que es importante y a pesar de que sí
que es cierto que este discurso
climático está cada vez entrando más
fuerte en las conversaciones
internacionales en los mítines en los
encuentros entre los diferentes países
el secretario general ha hecho hincapié
en que se necesita un compromiso por
parte de los países más desarrollados en
que van a reducir su emisión de gases
que provocan el efecto invernadero
porque al final estos países más
desarrollados son los responsables
históricos de esta crisis climática que
estamos atravesando